[موسيقى]
الكتاب كان محاوله
للتجوال داخل
ذهن السلطه وداخل مطبخها وكيف تحدث
التقلبات داخل
ذهن السلطه وكيف تنتقل
وهذا التطور والتحول الذي رصته
كان بمثابه مؤشر قوي لكثير من الناس ان
هذه الحركه قد وصلت الى طريق مسدود وان
كنت عندما كتبت الكتاب لما كنا اعتقد هذا
الاعتقاد ولكن بعد ان كتبت الكتاب في
المسار المراجعات المستمر وبتامل الحركات
الاسلاميه في العالم كله وليس السودان فقط
انتهيت الى نتيجه ان الاسلام السياسي قد
استنفذ اغراضه
بمعنى ان الرؤيا والفكره والاطروحه قد
جربت في مستويات مختلفه بما فيها مستوى
الدوله واثبت انها غير قادره على الاجابه
على اسئله العصر ولذلك لا بد من نقله
جديده وانا دعوت الى القطيع النفسيه
والمعرفيه مع ماضي الحركات الاسلاميه التي
بدات في القرن قبل الماضي مع الافغاني
والرضا ومحمد عبده والبنا
[موسيقى]
انسان يريد ان يتصدى لتحويل المجتمع الى
مجتمع اسلامي عليه ان يجيب على اسئله
المناهج الحديثه التي بحثت في القران
وبحثت في الحديث وبحثت في الحاله الحضاريه
كلها